on
kaka
[Applaudissements]
avez vous remarqué la différence de
maturité neurologiques d'un bébé cheval
et d'un bep les humains c'est flagrant
me direz vous mais nos bébés sont en
poussette jusqu'à un an
et oui est ce pour cela que les
neuroscientifiques disent de nous que
nous naissons prématurée c'est peut-être
vrai après tout 26 octobre 2006 je suis
la sage-femme de garde en maternité
chambre 810 une grand-mère n'interpelle
vous arrivez bien pouvez-vous dire à ma
fille que j'ai raison qu'elle ne doit
pas porter son bébé trop souvent elle va
lui donner de mauvaises habitudes
et naturellement il va devenir
capricieux j'ai de quoi je parle
j'en ai élevé 3 ce discours vous l'avez
déjà certainement entendu ou même
peut-être penser que nous disent les
neuroscientifiques le professeur antonio
damasio écrit pour notre survie nous
nous appuyons sur ce que nous
connaissons grâce à nos cinq sens
ce bébé que connaît-il sur quoi
s'appuient t-il
quelles sont ses sens développé à la
naissance il reconnaît la voix séparant
le rythme cardiaque maternelle la forme
et la chaleur des mains qu'il a perçu au
travers du muscle utérin
si sa maman la lettre le goût du lait
maternel est identique à celui du
liquide amniotique
c'est grâce à ce liquide amniotique qui
le caressent tout au long de la
grossesse que son sens du toucher et le
sens le plus développé à la naissance
ses parents sont donc sa passerelle
souvenirs entre son monde ancien et son
nouveau monde
pour survivre nous naissons avec six
émotions primaires 5 émotions négatives
la peur la tristesse
moi je laime trop utile et trop chaud
trop chaud
le dégoût ça vraiment pas l'air bon la
surprise
regardez les sourcils et la colère et
une seule émotion positive la joie
sachant que nos cinq sens sont les
déclencheurs dans notre système limbique
de nos émotions sécurisé rassurez nous
construisons des émotions secondaire
positive portée 24 heures sur 24 et
jamais seul durant toute la grossesse
ce bébé si depuis sa naissance il est
porté huit heures par des parents
bienveillants
ce bébé à deux tiers de sa vie de
changer aimeriez vous quand vous changez
votre vide deux tiers applaudissez vous
un changement même minime dans votre vie
dans votre travail dormez-vous serein
al'annonce de ce changement
pour lui comme pour nous c'est
déstabilisant alors porter le bébé maman
kangourou papa va koala souvent porté
dans une haie charasse sûrs et sécurisés
il dort paisiblement il met 100 jours
pour se déshabituer de son portage in
utero 24 heures sur 24
c'est dans les premières semaines que
son horloge interne se met en place
grâce à l'habituation à son
environnement stable et à sa maturation
neurologiques ses plages de sommeil
s'allonge petit à petit à six mois 85 %
des bébés dorment de six à huit heures
par nuit voire plus
pour les parents chanceux eh oui au
début il s'endort toujours dans vos bras
ou au sein pour les mamans qui allaitent
à son jour sa chance auto rassurés ils
sont dorcel les réveils sont toujours
bruyant
ils appellent pour savoir si vous êtes
là votre présence votre voix son cadre
de vie toujours identique le rassure
grâce à l'habituation à 100 jours les
trois sieste se met en place une petite
le matin une petite en fin de journée et
une plus importante en milieu de journée
toujours dans le même cadre
naturellement et à heure fixe sa mémoire
haptique vous savez la mémoire
essentiellement liée au toucher a été
étudié dans le laboratoire de cognition
de l'université descartes à paris par
adam arlette strelli les capacités des
bébés sont impressionnantes des
capacités de stockage de rétention le
rappel ou la reconnaissance des éléments
pris dans son cadre de vie se met en
place dans les 100 jours
ils disent de nos bébés qu'ils sont
câblés avis d'où l'importance de
ritualiser au maximum ces journées de ne
pas trop le sortir d'être un son rythme
oui j'ai bien dit à son rythme pendant
les cent jours même si vous êtes
sollicités par des invitations
sachez dire non votre objectif est le
bien-être de tous les trois
même si votre entourage
vous conseille le contraire ah les bons
conseils de l'enclos à reims et oui vous
savez tu vas quand même pas changer de
vie pour un bébé c'est à lui de se
mettre à ton rythme enfin il faut bien
qu'ils s'habituent
non non non à son rythme durant les 11
jours sa mémoire non déclaratives est
aussi en route
le professeur bauer de l'université
emory aux états unis écrit les
nourrissons sont capables de se forger
des souvenirs même si à l'âge adulte ils
sont incapables de se les remémorer ils
sont dans l'inconscient les émotions
facilite la formation de souvenirs et
nous savons tous que la formation des
souvenirs fondent l'identité personnelle
et sociale de l'individu
d'où l'importance du portage de répondre
à chaque appel de ce fait rassuré il
acquiert pour plus tard
les bases d'une grande autonomie c'est
dans notre cerveau limbique ou cerveau
émotionnel que sont stockés les
informations et la mémoire
mais c'est aussi là que vont s'élaborer
les prises de décision et les
apprentissages
je voulais juste de l'impact des 100
jours sur notre système neurologique en
madame verts qui étudie les vocalises
des bébés et constate que les bébés
vocalises dans la langue entendu in
utero un bébé japonais babillant
japonais un bébé russe s'exprime en
russe
vos bébés vous appelle pour attirer
votre attention dans la langue qu'il a
entendus durant la grossesse
vous lui répondez dans la même langue
c'est le mam année certains disent ils
crient connotation colère d'autres il
pleure connotation tristesse douleur
pourquoi ne pas tout simplement dire il
appelle on a tous entendu des parents
traduire les appels des enfants il a
faim il a soif
il veut être changée il a sommeil il est
fatigué est-ce de la communication la
communication eiffel de 7% de parole 38%
d'intonation et 55% de gestuelle il lui
manque que 7 % en 1988 le docteur
challamel à lyon écrit c'est en imitant
ce parent que le bébé construit ses
mimiques faciales
voilà un bébé calédoniens de sept jours
il imite drôlement bien son papa vous
trouvez pas le docteur bohlinger lui
associe les mimiques faciales aussi
émotions primaires que nous avons vu
précédemment vos bébés des codes vos
émotions au travers de vos intonations
et de vos mimiques faciales regarder une
contagion émotionnelle
je dirais la joie votre bébé vous
ressemble il est à votre image
alors parlez lui à moins de 30 cm pour
qu'il vous voit bien il se sait compris
votre communication est bien meilleure
les liens affectifs sont resserrés à
deux mois vous décoder déjà bien le
langage les bébés mais avant de moi me
direz vous
je vous donne les astuces de vieilles
sage femme
mon mode d'emploi cercle approximatif
des trois cris des trois pleure si vous
le voulez bien je vais plutôt dire des
trois appels premier type d'appel il
appelle ce bébé vous le prenez il
s'apaise et bien la communication est
parfaite
vous avez parfaitement répondu à sa
demande
vous gardez dans vos bras ou en écharpe
si vous avez une autre occupation
affaire ait besoin de vos mains bravo
vous avez répondu
deuxième type d'appel il appelle foule
prenait ils continuent de manifester
cela fait moins d'une heure qu'il a fini
de tt cela fait moins de deux heures
qu'il a fini son biberon c'est la
digestion la digestion peut être
désagréable voire très très très
désagréable
son réflexe de succion est exacerbée
souvent ses jambes sont repliés sur son
abdomen
alors eh bien masser l'huile vendre
donnez lui votre petit doigt à téter ou
votre avant-bras et marchés pour qu'ils
retrouvent en mémoire son temps ou du
terrain où tout était parfait et dans
les 15 minutes
tous se calent tranquillement
paisiblement et vous lui dites je
partage ton un confort on est ensemble
et les décibels sont parfois très élevés
donc ce papa pour rester sereins a opté
pour un casque audio troisième type
d'appel
il appelle vous le prenez tu viens de
doux et ils continuent de manifester
cela fait plus d'une heure qu'il a fini
de tt cela fait plus de deux heures
qu'il a fini son biberon et bien vous
lui dites j'ai bien compris tu as faim
et vous le mettez au sein ou vous lui
donnez son biberon
il se sait compris la communication est
parfaite
il n'y a eu aucune parole de sa part à
100 jours vous êtes complètement
bilingue deuxième langue
le mam année et le couple me direz vous
eh bien il faut 100 jours au couple pour
qu'il retrouve sa place
saint geours c'est aussi le moment où
souvent les mamans reprennent le travail
cent jours c'est le temps qu'il faut pas
pas pour qu'ils changent de rythme pour
qu'ils s'investissent dans son nouveau
rôle il faut aussi mesdames que vous
acceptiez que les papas fasse aussi bien
que vous mais différemment mais aussi
bien oui oui mesdames alléger votre
charge mentale
je n'ai jamais vu de papa je peux vous
le garantir
prendre un bébé comme ça
jamais ni donner un biberon comme ça
donc rassurez vous ils font aussi bien
que nous mais différemment
il faut aussi accepter que les bébés
soient moins en demande ne pas les
déranger ne pas les prendre quand ils
sont calmes tranquille paisible même si
vos visites ont envie de les cajoler les
dorloter voire de les embrasser
est ce un jouet convenait que c'est une
personnalité en devenir
alors laissez le rêver laissez le jouer
laissez-les découvrir le monde en toute
autonomie
rassurez vous ils vous appellent quand
il a besoin de vous n'est ce pas notre
rôle parental toute notre vie de
répondre aux demandes de nos enfants
sans toutefois les anticiper la
personnalité humaine et comme une maison
pour que la construction soit stable et
durable pour que les murs élèves
viendront les fondations certes
invisible doit faire l'objet d'une
attention toute particulière
les 100 jours sont la fondation de cet
édifice humain alors soyez cohérent
donnez-lui saint geours donnez-vous 100
jours pour vous adapter à ce
bouleversant changement qui est la
construction d'une famille
c'est par le réconfort
le dialogue le portage qu'on va
vers l'autonomie cela sent peut-être
contre-intuitif peut-être contraire à
nos habitudes
cela va à l'encontre des conseils qu'on
nous donne
porter le bébé portait le le portage
mène à une quand d'autonomie des deux
ans
c'est le paradoxe des singes voir merci
[Applaudissements]
tard